DIVIDE STUDENTS BY RE, WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT CRT IS TRYING TO
DO.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
FROM A FORMER FLORIDA
ATTORN GENERAL PAM BONDI COME
ALONG WITH SENIOR FELLOW OF T
WHO.
INSTITUTION VICTOR DAVIS HANSON,
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HE.
WE DID A LITTLE QUICK RESEARCH.
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE DISNEYLAND
IS LOCATED, DNEY DOESOT HAVE
A SANCTUARYOUNTRY INSIDE OF
CAFORNIA WHERE THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN DISTINCT TAX STAS.
YET DEMOCTS ARE LOSING THEIR
MIND OVER THEACT THAT FLORIDA
SIMPLY LEVELING THE PLAYING
ELD AND SAYING HEY, DISNEY,
YOU DON'T GET TO BE YR OWN
COUNTRY.>> YEAH, THAT IS EXACTL,
PE, AND THOSE WOKE EXECUTIVES
THAT LIVE IN CALIFORNIA PAY
ABOUT 40% MORE IN THEIR TAXES
THAN T EXECUTIVES THAT LIVE IN
THE GREAT STATEF FLORIDA, SO,
YOU KNOW, WE PASSED THIS BL IN
FLORIDA AND I AM SO PROUD OF
WION SIMPSON, OUR SENATE
PRESIDENT AND OUR GOVNOR FOR
FINDING IT AND BRINGING LIG ON
IT.
THIS IS WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT.
THE FIRST BILL,HE PARENTAL
RIGH BILL, AS YOU SAID, IT IS
PROTECTING 5, 6, 7, AND8-YEAR-O.
IN A GARDEN THROUGH THIRD
GRADERS.
THIRD-GRADERS, FROM NOT TALKING
ABOUT SEX IN SCHLS.
I THINK ANY PARENT IN AMERICA
WOULD AGREE TH THAT.
PAST, DONE, GAT LAW, THEN IT
DISNEY COMESN AND LIE ABOUT
OUR GOVERNOR AND OUR SENATE AND
OUR HOUSE THEY LIE ABOUT WHAT
PARENTS WANT IN THE STATE OF
FLORID AND THEY A HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHATHEY DID -- WHAT THEYDIDN'T R
LANE IS ENTERTAINING FAMIES
AND MAKING MON FOR THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS.
YET THEY SHINED A HUGE SPOTLIGHT
ON THEMSELVES.
THISAW IS 55 YEARS OLD.
NONE OF US ACTUALLY KNEW THE
EXTENT OF THE PRIVILEGES THAT
DISNEY HAD AN OUR OWN KINGDOM
AND NOW THEY'RE TAKEN AWAY.
>> YEAH, AND THEIR LANE USED TOE
WHOLESOME CONTENT THAT
PARENTS COULD COUNT ON AND NOW
TURN ON DISY PLUS AND YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT WOKE SERIES YOU.
VICTOR, WHEN YOU LOOK AT TH,
IT USED TO BE DEMOCRATS THAT
WOULD FIGHT AGAINST CORPORATE
CARVE OUTS OR TAX BREAKS FOR BIG
BUSINESSES.
NOW THEY ARE FALLINGVER
EMSELVES TO PROTECT THEM.
WHY THIS CHAE, VICTOR?
>> I DON'T THINK - I THINK IT
IS JUST A MATTER OF WE AREOING
TO FORCE THIS DOW PEOPLE'S
THROATS A HOW DARE YOU OBJECT
TO US.
IT ISIGHLY IRONIC, DISNEY HAS
A MARKET OF $300 MILLION AND
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT DISNEY'S
AUTONOUS ZONE AND ALL THE
LEGISLATORS THAT ISET'S GO
BACK TO NORMALITY.
DISNEY IS I A BAD PLACE BECAUSE
HOW MANY PLACES IN THE
UNIT STATES HAVE 20 MILLION
PEOPLE AND AN ALL-WEATHER
CLIMATE, MAYE FLORIDA,
CALIFORNIA, AND TEXAS.
THAT IS ABOUT IT.
YOU NEED A BIG PULATION, YOU
NEED WARM WEATHE THEY ARE AT
THE MERCY AND IT IS VERY IRONIC
BECAUSE REMEMBER THE LASTECADE
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT PRIVATE
BUSINESS CAN REALLY FORCE THESE
CONSVATIVE STATES TO THEIR
KNEES SOF THEYAVE I.D. LAWS,
MAJOR LEAGUE BASALL WILL
BOYCOTT THEM OR SOUTHAROLINA
HAS JUST CLERICAL BATHROOMS
AND ALL OF OUR CALIFORNIA
COANIES HERE WILL ST OUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
REALLY IT IS NOT EVEN EQUAL YET,
BUT THE STATES AREAYING, WE
CAN DO THIS, T, WE CAN PASS
LAWS THAT REFLECT OUR VALUES
JUST LIKE YOU CAN BOYCOTTUR
STATES, BUT THEY GET HYSTERICAL.
THE SUBTEXT OF ALL OF THIS,
WHETHER IT IS ITICAL RACE
THEORY IN THE SCHOOLS OR IT IS
ANSGENDERRISM, OPEN BORDERS,
51 PERCENT DO NOT AGREE WITH
THESE IDEOGIES.
NONEF THESE AGENDAS, THEY
EITHER HAVE TO CHANGE THE
DEGRAPHY OR THEY HAVE TO
INDOCTRINATE YOU PEOPLE.
AND WEINGARTEN TALKS ABOUT WARS,
IT IS KIND OF IRONIC TT SHE
WAS RIGHT, INDOCTRINATION OF
YOUNG KIDS, WHETHER IN THE
THIRD REICH ORHE SOVIET SYSTEM
OR MAOIST CHI WAS ESSTIAL TO
CREATING AN AUTOCRACY AND
TALITARIAN IDEOLOGY WHICH WE
KNOW HOW THAT A ENDED FOR
EVERYONE.
SO THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE DOI
BECAUSE THEY DON'T -- THE CAN'T
WIN THE PEOPLE.
THEYON'T HAVE AN EFFECTIVE,
PERSUASIVE ANDA.
THE PEOPLE HAV REJECTED IT.
THEY ARE GNG CRAZY AND ARE
SAYING WE'VE GOT TO GO TO THE
KIDS TN, OR WE'VE GOT TO BRING
IN NEW PEOPLE OR WE HAVE TO
CHANGE T SYSTEM BECAUSE WE
CAN'T WIN ANYMORE BECAU WE
HAVE GONE OFF THE DEEP END.
>> Pete: PAM THAT FEELS RIGHT
TO.IT FEELS LIKE THE WOKE VERSUS
THE NEWLY AWAKE, WHO REAZE
THEY TAKE IT FOR GRANTED FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE REACTION
HONESTLY AMONG A POLITICAL
INDEPEENCE INSIDE FLORIDA
BASED ON THE MISCHARACTEZATION
OF THIS BILL, HOW DO THEY REALLY
FEEL IT?
>> WELL, FLORIDIANS EVERYWHERE,
THEY CAN'T BELIEVE COME I THINK
DISNEY -- PEOPLE ARE GIVG UP
DISNEY PLUS, THEY ARE GIVING UP
THEIR SEAS PASSES.
DISNEY, THE DIDN'T STAY IN
THEIR LANE AND THEY ARE WRO
AND THEY LIED ABOUT OUR STATE
AND THEY LIED ABOUT WHAT OUR
PANTS WANT IN OUR STATE AND
TH ARE SUPPOSED TO BE T
ORGANIZATION THAT LOOKS OUT FOR
FAMILIES, YETHEY ARE ENJOYGA PRS
NOT ENJOY, SEE WORLD DOES NOT
ENJOY, OUR MUSEUMS DON'T HAVE,
OUR AQUARIUMS DON'T HE, AND
NOW WE ARE LEVELING THE PLAYINGA
AND THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
ABIDE BY IT AND IT WAS THEIR
MISTAKE BECAUSE THEY BROUGHT
THIS TLIGHT ON THEMSELVES, AND
YOU KNOW, IN FLORIDA, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO PUT UP WITH THESE WOKE
CORPORIONS, IT'S UNBELIEVABLE
WE ARE EN HAVING TO TALK ABOUT
THIS, ANDN OUR SCHOOL ROOMS
AND IN OUR CLASSROOMS, THE BOOKS
THAT THEY ARE PUTTINGUT THERE,
IT IS TRULY UNREAL, BUT INHE
STATE OF FLORIDA, WERE GOING
TO LOOK OUT FORARENTS AND
CHILDREN AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THA.
>> Pete: VICTOR,E DON'T HAVE
MUCH TIME AND I IS KD OF A
BIG QUESTION BUT DO THE BEST YOU
N, IS THE LEFT CAPABLE OFNY
LF-REFLECTION BASED ON
ELECTORA VIABILITY, OR DO THEY
HAVE TO DOUBLE DOWN BECAUSE OF
THEIR THIRS FOR IDEOLOGY AND
CONTROL?
>> THEY ARE IDEOLOGUES.
THEY ARE NOT CAPABLE OF ANY
CONCESSIONS OR MODERATION, THATY
HAVE HIJACKED THEEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY WOULD RATHER LOSE AND BE
IDEOLOGICALLY CORCT THAN WIN
AND BE IDEOLOGICALLY INCORRECT.
THESERE SINS OF NOT JUST
COMMISSION, PETE, THEY ARE
OMISSION THAT THEY ASSE THAT
THESE FIRST, SECOND, THIRD
GRERS ARE GETTING GREAT
EDUCATION IN ART AND MUSIC AND
LITERATURE A LANGUAGE.
TH ARE SO WELL TAUGHT BY THESE
BRILLIANT TEACHERS THAT THEY
HAVE TIME TO TEACH
TRANSGENDER-IS ON.
THAT SHOULD BE THE LAST THING
UNTIL THEY GET THE BASICS A WE
KNOW OUR KIDS ARE NOT GETTING A
GOOD EDUCATION AT ALL.
>> Pete: YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
OK HOW THE 2022 MIDTERMS, IF
DEMOCRATS GET WIPED OUT, WATCH
EM SAY IT IS BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T LE